Speaker 1: Dr. Anthony Fauci has COVID and
Donald Trump's former doctor, now Congressman
Ronny Jackson, is just thrilled. He is gleeful.
He's bursting at the seams with excitement that
Dr. Anthony Fauci has COVID. Now, we we learned
about this in the last couple of days. Yesterday,
I guess it was Dr. Anthony Fauci. Tests positive
for COVID is experiencing mild symptoms.
He's 81 years old. He's fully vaccinated. He's
been boosted twice. He has mild symptoms and will
isolate and work from home. He's taking Paxil,
COVID, the Anti-Covid drug and will follow the
guidelines of the CDC. Okay. So, well, he's an
81 year old, not an age that you necessarily
love to get COVID at, but he's doing okay. What
does Congressman Ronny Jackson tweet? I think you
all know Ronny Jackson tweets, quote, Sad to see
that despite vaccines, boosters, multiple masks
and social distancing, Fauci has contracted COVID.
I hope you get well very soon, exclamation point.
I mean, a more more sarcastic well-wishes are hard
to imagine. You'll need to be in tip top shape
when the Republican majority takes Congress. Lots
of testifying while under investigation next year.
It's great to see that a fellow doctor I mean,
that guys think think about how disgusting this
Ronnie Jackson guy is a fellow doctor. Oh, I hope
you're going to need to be in tip top shape. I
hope you get well soon because you're going to be
under investigation when we take over next year.
Now, statistically, statistically, Dr. Fauci has
mild symptoms because he's vaccinated and boosted.
81 year olds unvaccinated who get COVID have
statistically worse outcomes, significantly worse
outcomes. That's a very at risk group 80 plus,
I think it's 75 plus, in fact. And so you can
never make any claim about an individual, right?
So when someone dies unvaccinated, we can't say
they would have survived if they were vaccinated.
We don't know that we can. Just talking in large
numbers. Statistically speaking, someone who died
unvaccinated would have had a much better shot had
they been vaccinated. So all we can say about
Dr. Fauci is statistically an unvaccinated 81
year old would fare worse against the virus than
someone who has been vaccinated and boosted. And
speaking of that, since we haven't talked about
COVID for a while, there's a really interesting
new study in the journal Health Affairs, which
actually looked at the PARTIZAN divide on
COVID mortality. We've talked generally before
about this and before I've told you, you know,
if you just generally take a look at COVID deaths
in Trump voting counties versus Biden voting
counties, there's definitely a correlation where
the Trump voting county counties have more deaths
per capita. This has now been studied. And this
is this is a very good study. The study is called
the Association between COVID 19 Mortality and the
County Level Partizan Divide in the United States.
And when you look at the abstract, the results are
very clear. The abstract says we found a positive
dose response relationship between county level
Republican vote share and county level COVID 19
mortality. This means the higher Trump vote, the
more COVID death majority Republican counties
experienced 73 additional deaths per 100,000
people relative to the majority Democratic
counties during the study period. And COVID
vaccine uptake explains approximately 10%
of the difference. Now, that's interesting
as well. Vaccination is only one part of why
the death rate is higher in Republican counties.
Because the abstract goes on to say Our findings
suggest that county level voting behavior may
act as a proxy for compliance with and support
of public health measures that would protect
residents from COVID 19. So bottom line,
what they what they found is you look at
Republican counties and Democratic counties,
Republican counties have a higher death rate
from COVID, partially that's explained by the
Republican counties having a lower vaccination
rate, but partially it's explained by less
adherence to public health guidelines in those
Republican counties, which presumably includes
masking, social distancing, etc.. Not a shock.
Not a shock. We intuitively knew this early on.
We saw general data pointing this way early on,
and now we have an actual proper study about it.
Not a shock. We wish Dr. Fauci our best and hope
he recovers soon. And you can find more on all of
these stories on The David Pakman Show Instagram.
That's at The David Pakman Show on Instagram.